See the tits straight ahead? Yeah. It's everywhere. Yeah, we go go straight. That car right there. Homeless. Most of my interviews with Tilly Shalee took place in a car. Come to think of it, most of my interviews with homeless people in general took place in cars.
看到前面那辆车了吗？对。到处都是。对，我们直走。就那辆车。无家可归。我和蒂莉莎·夏利（Tilly Shalee）的大部分采访都是在一辆车里进行的。仔细想想，我跟无家可归之人的大部分采访其实都是在车里进行的。
Cars are good as studios. They're quiet, they don't have an echo. They are less good as homes. But many, many people in Oakland are using them that way. Do you alright? Mm-hmm. They're fair right there. Tilecia is pointing out all the people sleeping in cars on just a few blocks in the East Oakland.
车子当工作室挺合适的。它们很安静，没有回音。但作为家，它们就没那么合适了。不过奥克兰有非常多的人正把车当成家。你还好吗？嗯嗯。他们就在那儿。蒂莱西亚（Tilecia）指出了所有睡在车里的人，仅仅在东奥克兰的几个街区里就有这么多。
Sometimes you really can't tell when a car has a person living in it. But often there are signs. Blinkets covering windows, suitcases, strap, torruves. Them cars right there. There's a car right here. I know these people right here. I know Them cars right there. This car right here. I know these people right here. I know these people right here. I know them people right there. All homeless.
有时候你真的很难看出哪辆车里住着人。但通常会有迹象。遮住车窗的毯子、手提箱、带子、各种杂物。就那些车。这里有辆车。我认识这车里的人。我认识那些车。就这辆车。我认识这些人。我认识这些人。我认识那些人。全都是无家可归的人。
All homeless in their cars. Oakland recorded 727 people sleeping in cars in 2019, although that's widely considered to be an undercount, especially because folks in vehicles tend to be less visible than say people in tents. Tileisha is good at spotting these cars because she knows this neighborhood, but there's another reason too. Sometimes she and her 11 year old son Jordan also sleep in the car. So you see what it's up? Yeah, I put my seat back somewhere.
全都是睡在车里的无家可归者。奥克兰在2019年记录到有727人睡在车里，尽管这被普遍认为是一个被低估的数字，特别是住在车里的人往往比住在帐篷里的人更不引人注目。蒂莱西亚很擅长发现这些车，因为她熟悉这个社区，但还有另一个原因。有时她和她11岁的儿子约旦（Jordan）也睡在车里。所以你知道怎么弄吗？对，我把座位往后调一点。
I would just have to record it right here for a minute. We got all the cover. Then I grabbed my feet double. So my feet won't be cold because in the middle of the night my feet be real cold. Delisha is in the driver's seat and her son Jordan is in shotgun. She has a round face and a wide smile with a little gap between her front teeth. She wears a beanie to keep her head warm and to cover the short hair she hasn't had the money to get done the way she likes it with extensions. Mom.
我得在这儿录一会儿。我们把所有遮挡物都弄好。然后我抓住我的双层脚套。这样我的脚就不会冷了，因为半夜的时候我的脚真的会很冷。蒂莱西亚坐在驾驶座上，她的儿子约旦坐在副驾驶座上。她长着一张圆脸，笑容灿烂，前牙之间有一条小缝。她戴着一顶毛线帽来保暖，也是为了遮住那些她没钱去美发店接发、打理成自己喜欢的样子的短发。妈妈。
Yeah. What did what to think about. What do you think about daddy? We need a house. We need a house. A house cord. We need a house, a car. We need a house on wheels. Jordan has his mom's same round face plus a round belly to match.
嗯。你觉得……你觉得爸爸怎么样？我们需要一个房子。我们需要一个房子。一个真正的房子。我们需要一个房子，一辆车。我们需要一辆带轮子的房子。约旦有着和他妈妈一样的圆脸，还有一个与之相配的圆滚滚的肚子。
He's gentle and shy. He likes video games and math. And Tilecia says she's thankful he isn't trying to act all grown like some kids his age. By the way, Jordan has a disability that affects his speech and language. We use some good dry. We can dry, pull over and go to sleep. Okay. drive and pull over and go to sleep. Yep. OK.
他温和而害羞。他喜欢电子游戏和数学。蒂莱西亚说，她很庆幸他不像同龄的一些孩子那样装成大人。顺便说一句，约旦有残疾，这影响了他的言语和语言能力。我们用点干的。我们可以擦干，然后把车停路边去睡觉。好吧。开车，靠边停车，然后睡觉。对。好吧。
That's what you want. That's what you're just thinking about. Yep. I'm nice, home. I'm nice home, too, huh? Even though mommy like the drive, we're just the drive. By 2019, T'Lisa and Jordan had been homeless for five years. Sometimes they stayed with family or friends and sometimes they ended up in the car.
这就是你想要的。这就是你一直在想的。对。我想要个好家。我也想要个好家，对吧？尽管妈妈喜欢开车，我们只是在开车。到2019年，蒂莉莎和约旦已经无家可归五年了。有时他们寄宿在家人或朋友家，有时则落脚在车里。
For five years, they'd mostly just struggled through homelessness on their own. But then something changed and they finally started trying to get some help. This is according to need, chapter 1. I want to zero in on the time when Tileisha started asking for help so that we can see what that looks like and start to see who the system works for and who it fails. But first, I want to go back. Should I get in with you? We could get in your car. You want to get in my car?
这五年里，他们大多只是靠自己艰难地熬过无家可归的日子。但后来情况发生了变化，他们终于开始尝试寻求一些帮助。这就是“按需分配”（According to Need）第一章。我想把焦点放在蒂莱西亚开始寻求帮助的那段时期，以便我们看看那是什么样的，并开始了解这个系统到底对谁有用，又对谁失效了。但首先，我得回溯一下。我要跟你一起上车吗？我们可以坐你的车。你想上我的车吗？
Yeah. OK. I got all the job. Tileisha told me about her life in a series of interviews we did in the car. She had never had it easy. The stuff that I went to when I was little, it taught me my survival
对。好吧。我把所有工作都安排好了。蒂莱西亚在车里进行的一系列采访中向我讲述了她的人生。她的人生从来都不是一帆风顺的。我小时候经历的那些事，教会了我生存的……
skills. Deletia's family was poor growing up. Both of her parents struggled with addiction and she had her first kid at 16. I didn't get a chance to enjoy my teenage years because I was a mom. There were so many obstacles and so much instability in Deletia's life. But somehow by the time she was in her 30s, she'd managed to get her GED, her forklifting license, and a good union job with benefits at Berkeley Farms Milk Plant. But then things started to unravel. It felt like there was one family crisis after another. I just went through a lot emotionally and then my mom, she was sick and using drugs and
技能。蒂莱西亚的家庭在她成长过程中很穷。她的父母都挣扎于毒瘾，她在16岁时就生下了第一个孩子。我没有机会享受我的青少年时期，因为我成了一个母亲。蒂莱西亚的生活中充满了障碍和动荡。但不知何故，到了三十多岁时，她设法取得了普通高中同等学历证书（GED）、叉车驾驶证，并在伯克利农场牛奶厂（Berkeley Farms Milk Plant）找到了一份待遇不错、有福利的工会工作。但随后事情开始失控。感觉就像是一个家庭危机接着另一个家庭危机。我在情感上经历了太多，然后我妈妈生病了，还吸毒，
in and out of hospital and it just got to the porch. I was tired, Katie. Tileesh has started missing work at the plant. Eventually, she lost her job and shortly thereafter, her apartment. In 2014, she became homeless. For a while, she and Jordan found places to crash and she worked temp jobs on and off, but they could only stay in one place for so long.
频繁进出医院，事情发展到了那个地步。我很累，凯蒂。蒂莱西亚开始旷工。最终，她失去了工作，不久之后，她的公寓也没了。2014年，她无家可归了。有一段时间，她和约旦找到了落脚的地方，她也断断续续地做着临时工，但他们在一个地方呆不了太久。
You know, some people live different from how you used to live in. Some people are dirty, some people are clean. Some people get high and you don't get high. Somebody be like, you come over here for a few days, you get them some money, you eat and stuff and then after that they act funny or feel like they want their space and put you out. They'd stay somewhere for a few months or a few weeks, and then it would be time to move on. Years passed like this.
你知道的，有些人的生活方式和你过去习惯的不同。有些人很脏，有些人很干净。有些人吸毒，而你不吸毒。有人会说，你过来待几天吧，你给他们一点钱，你们一起吃东西什么的，然后过了一段时间，他们就开始变得古怪，或者觉得需要自己的空间，就把你赶出去。他们会在某个地方待几个月或几周，然后就得继续搬迁。岁月就这样流逝。
Eventually, the instability started to wear until he was just mental health. Because being homeless mentally is trouble. Especially when your child acts you. When you pick them up from school, mom, where are we going to go? your child actually, when you pick them up from school, mom, where are we gonna go? Mom, where are we gonna eat?
最终，这种动荡开始侵蚀蒂莉的心理健康。因为精神上的无家可归是一种折磨。尤其是当你的孩子问你的时候。当你接他放学时，“妈妈，我们要去哪里？”当你的孩子问你的时候，当你接他放学时，“妈妈，我们要去哪里？”“妈妈，我们去哪儿吃东西？”
Tileja felt like she was treading water, just barely staying afloat. Or maybe she wasn't staying afloat at all, it was actually slowly drowning. She desperately needed a life raft, but there was no one stable enough in her life to grab onto. Everyone around her was also struggling.
蒂莱莎感觉自己像是在踩水，勉强维持不沉下去。或者也许她根本没有维持住，其实是在慢慢溺水。她迫切需要一个救生艇，但她生活里没有一个足够稳定的人可以依靠。她周围的每个人也都在苦苦挣扎。
I was to the point where I was really trying to figure out where can I place and put my son that I can't provide for him to wait. I want to let a family member have him for a while, you know, where he could eat, sleep, bathe, be cleat, smoke-free environment, you know stuff like that. And I could picture or figure out one person. In 2018, after four years of bouncing around from place to place, Tilecia suffered a psychotic break.
我当时的想法真的是在琢磨，我能把我的儿子安置在哪里、送到哪里去呢？因为我无力抚养他，只能等。我想让某个家人带他一段时间，你知道的，至少在那里他可以吃饱、睡觉、洗澡、保持干净、生活在一个无烟的环境里，你知道诸如此类的事。而我能想到或找出的人只有一个。2018年，在四处流浪了四年之后，蒂莱西亚遭遇了一次精神崩溃。
For a couple of months, she had delusions that she was famous and wealthy, and she got aggressive when people tried to convince her otherwise. When I started doing stuff, I don't usually do. That's when I knew I need a help. During this time, while she was driving by herself, Talisha crashed her car on purpose into a wall.
有几个月的时间，她产生了妄想，觉得自己既出名又富有，当别人试图说服她并非如此时，她会变得具有攻击性。当我开始做一些我平时不会做的事情时。我那时就知道我需要帮助了。在这期间，当她独自开车时，蒂莱西亚故意把车撞向了一堵墙。
She didn't want to die. It was more like a cry for help. And I sent to myself, if I hit that pole, I'm gonna die. If I hit that brick wall, I can survive, but I'm gonna be. So I said, let the pole and I just turn the wheel. After the crash, Tilecia went to a regular hospital and then a psychiatric hospital, where she was diagnosed with PTSD among other things. And then, like she's always done, she clawed her way back to some fragile semblance of sanity.
她并不想死。这更像是一种对帮助的呼喊。我对自己说，如果我撞上那根电线竿，我就会死。如果我撞上那堵砖墙，我能活下来，但我会受伤。所以我说，那就选电线竿，然后我猛地打方向盘。车祸发生后，蒂莱西亚先去了一家普通医院，然后又去了一家精神病院，在那里她被诊断出患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）等多种疾病。然后，就像她一直以来所做的那样，她拼尽全力找回了一点脆弱的理智。
And that brings us to 2019, when Tleisha and Jordan still homeless had exhausted every last family or friend connection. There was nowhere left to go except for the car. The car is sacred Tullisha wears her keys on a lanyard around her neck. If it wasn't for the car she tells me they'd be living under a bridge. I just put my seat back, put my little thing to cover up the front window. We'll have our snacks and whatever else we eat, our cover. And we'll just go to sleep. Oh, my legs are killing me. Your leg?
这就把我们带到了2019年，当时蒂莱西亚和约旦仍然无家可归，他们已经用尽了最后每一个亲戚或朋友的关系。除了车里，已经无处可去了。汽车是神圣的。蒂莱西亚把钥匙挂在脖子上的挂绳上。如果不是因为这辆车，她告诉我，他们就得住在桥底下。我只要把座椅调后，把我的小东西挂在前面挡风玻璃上遮挡一下。我们吃点零食或者其他吃的，盖好被子。然后我们就直接睡觉。哦，我的腿快酸死了。你的腿？
Look. Why? It's not a killing me. There's no way you're laying. Oh, it's tight. You're getting a vaccine. Maybe I get bad dreams. If I go ahead of bad dreams. That's how the summer rolled forward.
看。为什么？它酸得厉害。你没法躺下。哦，太挤了。你这是在做噩梦。也许我会做噩梦。如果我预感到有噩梦的话。夏天就这样一天天过去。
Stiff necks and backs, sleeping in the car, washing their faces at McDonald's. But then, when the school year starts, something kind of incredible happens. Tilecia finally gets a life raft. Her name is Trish Anderson. Bless you girl, keep it up. Okay, YouTube bye bye.
脖子和背部僵硬，睡在车里，在麦当劳洗脸。但是后来，当学年开始时，发生了一件近乎不可思议的事情。蒂莱西亚终于得到了一艘救生艇。她的名字叫崔茜·安德森（Trish Anderson）。保佑你，姑娘，坚持下去。好的，你们俩，拜拜。
Keep it up. Okay. YouTube, bye bye. One day. Okay, let's see this one. Did you know because I did not know that every school district in the US has a person whose job is to help homeless families? Trish Anderson is that person in Oakland.
坚持下去。好的，你们俩，拜拜。有一天。好吧，我们来看看这个。你知道吗？因为我以前不知道，美国每个学区都有一个专门负责帮助无家可归家庭的工作人员？崔茜·安德森就是奥克兰的这个人。
Her title, the McKinney-Vento liaison, comes from the federal legislation that established the position. Trisha's office is in a little portable building behind an elementary school. She has about a dozen bracelets on each dress that clank on the table when she talks. And she lets me interview her between emails and phone calls. Hi Leslie, this is Trisha.
她的头衔是“麦金尼-温托法案联络员”（McKinney-Vento liaison），这个称呼来自确立该职位的联邦立法。崔茜的办公室在小学后面的一栋小型活动板房里。她的每个手腕上都戴着大约十几个手镯，说话时在桌子上叮当作响。她让我趁着回邮件和打电话的间隙采访她。嗨，莱斯利，我是崔茜。
Hi, so Leslie, I have a situation. I have a mom and a daughter. They're not in a car. They have no place to go. So mom moved here for me. Over the course of the 2017-2018 school year, public school data shows that some one and a half million students experienced homelessness across the country.
嗨，莱斯利，我这里有个情况。我有一个妈妈和一个女儿。她们不在车里。她们无处可去。所以妈妈搬到我这儿来了。2017-2018学年的数据显示，全美有大约150万名学生经历过无家可归。
These students tend to move with their parents from one part of town to another to another. And a big part of the McKinney Ventoli-Azons job is helping homeless parents enroll and re-enroll their kids in school. Trish does a lot of that, but she can also help with things like bus passes and uniforms. Sometimes they don't want one when I off, but I don't need transportation. I need a house. And I mean, that's real.
这些学生往往跟着父母从城镇的一个地方搬到另一个地方，再搬到另一个地方。而麦金尼-温托联络员工作的一大重点，就是帮助无家可归的父母为他们的孩子在学校注册和重新注册。崔茜做了很多这方面的工作，但她也可以提供公交卡和校服之类的帮助。有时他们不需要这些，当我提供时，他们会说，我不需要交通卡。我需要一个房子。我的意思是，这很现实。
Trish can't offer housing per se, although she can help parents fill out applications for apartments or search for affordable places on the internet. When a family and her program finally finds housing or shelter, they get a little construction paper house to put on the wall. So this one, someone went from car to shelter. So she decorated hers. Any movement we acknowledge.
崔茜本身提供不了住房，不过她可以帮家长填写公寓申请表，或者在网上寻找价格实惠的住所。当她项目中的一个家庭终于找到住房或收容所时，他们会得到一个小彩纸房子贴在墙上。所以这个，有人从车里搬进了庇护所。所以她装饰了自己的房子。我们认可他们的每一点进步。
So these are all. Trish has a big warm personality, but there's also something guarded underneath. When I ask her if she ever takes work home, she says she tries not to. She has her own problems at home. She's a caregiver for her son who skits a friend-ic and for her elderly mother who needs a lot of help with day-to-day tasks.
所以这些都是。崔茜性格热情开朗，但内心深处也有所防备。当我问她是否会把工作带回家时，她说她尽量不这样做。她家里也有自己的问题。她要照顾患有精神分裂症的儿子，还要照顾年迈的母亲，她母亲在日常事务上需要很多帮助。
But every now and again someone slips past her force field. Tullisha was like that. Trisha remembers seeing Tullisha at the beginning of the school year when she came to pick up a bus pass for Jordan. She was slid down in the chair, had on a hat, looked very tired. So I said, come here every day. Come here every day, have oatmeal hang out, find a tear, help me with my closet. I was like, okay.
但偶尔还是会有人突破她的心理防线。蒂莱西亚就是这样。崔茜还记得学年刚开始时看到蒂莱西亚的情景，当时她来为约旦领公交卡。她瘫坐在椅子上，戴着帽子，看起来非常疲惫。所以我说，每天都来这里。每天都来这里，吃燕麦片，消磨时间，找个地方坐坐，帮我整理衣柜。我当时想，好吧。
That's what I said, too. I was like, okay, actually I start going every day, every day. I have oatmeal, eat, get on a computer, look for resources. And while Tilly-Jow is there, Trish encouraged her to do something else too. Something she hadn't tried in a while. Call 211 and ask for help. 211 is a kind of hotline for homeless people
我也是这么说的。我当时想，好吧，其实我开始每天都来，每天都来。吃燕麦片，吃东西，用电脑，寻找资源。在蒂莱西亚呆在那里的时候，崔茜也鼓励她做另一件事。一件她有一段时间没尝试过的事。拨打211寻求帮助。211是一种热线电话，专门为无家可归的人提供服务，
who are looking for help with things like shelter or housing in Alameda County. Thank you so much for hoping. How can I assist you today? Yes, me and my 11-year-old son is home. And where have you and your son been sleeping on? Where did you stay at or sleep last night? In my car that don't run. Okay. So tomorrow you can go at 1 p.m. at the Henry Robinson Multiservice Center to do an assessment
他们正在阿拉米达县寻找庇护所或住房等方面的帮助。非常感谢您的致电。今天有什么我可以帮您的吗？是的，我和我11岁的儿子无家可归。你和你儿子一直在哪里睡觉？昨晚你们在哪里过夜或睡觉的？在我的车里，那辆车已经开不动了。好的。那么明天下午1点，你可以去亨利·鲁宾逊多服务中心（Henry Robinson Multiservice Center）进行评估，
for the CES program. When the operator says the CES program, she's using an acronym for the coordinated entry system. You're going to understand a lot more about this system by the end of this series. But for now, I'll just say that most communities in the US have a system like this. And one thing it does is create a big master list of homeless people that all the non-profits in a particular community are working off of. This helps to ensure that two different organizations aren't trying to assist the same person without knowing it.
以便进入CES项目。当接线员说出“CES项目”时，她使用的是“协调准入系统”（coordinated entry system）的缩写。到本系列节目结束时，你会对这个系统有更多的了解。但现在，我只想说，美国的大多数社区都有这样的系统。它的作用之一是建立一个庞大的无家可归者总名单，特定社区内的所有非营利组织都在依据这个名单开展工作。这有助于确保两家不同的组织在互不知情的情况下，不会同时试图去帮助同一个人。
Anyway, the operator is telling Tilly Shows she needs to get into this system in order to get help with housing. And that, unfortunately, there are no shelters to stay in in the meantime. There was no mom with child to be available right now. But I'm just trying to find something before it rains. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. OK. OK.
总之，接线员在告诉蒂莱西亚，她需要进入这个系统才能获得住房方面的帮助。但不幸的是，在此期间没有收容所可以入住。目前没有可供带孩子的母亲入住的房间。但我只是想在下雨前找个地方。对，对，完全是这样。好的。好的。
All right. Thank you. All right. Thank you for calling. Bye-bye. The next day, Tleisha took the bus to the nonprofit in downtown Oakland that the operator had told her about.
好的。谢谢您。好的。谢谢您的致电。再见。第二天，蒂莱西亚坐公交车去了接线员告诉她的、位于奥克兰市中心的那个非营利组织。
While she waited, she eyed the other people who were also there, everyone homeless, everyone in need. Eventually, it was Tullisha's turn and she answered some questions with a social worker named Yolanda. What is your monthly income, Yolanda asked her? $836 Tullisha answered. Tullisha didn't have a job at the time,
在她等待的时候，她打量着也在那里的其他人，每个人都无家可归，每个人都需要帮助。终于轮到蒂莱西亚了，她回答了一位名叫尤兰达（Yolanda）的社工提出的几个问题。你的月收入是多少？尤兰达问她。“836美元，”蒂莱西亚回答。蒂莱西亚当时没有工作，
but she got some money from the state because of Jordan's disability. Does anyone in your household suffer from depression? Yes. In the past 30 days have you had to do things that felt unsafe to survive? Yes. How often? Daily. There were more questions, and Yolanda entered Tilecia's answers and do a computer while they talked. The fact that they wanted to know so much about her seemed like a good sign to Tilecia. She felt hopeful, even though they were still sleeping in the car. It's so loud. What?
但她因为约旦的残疾从州里领到了一些钱。你家里有人患有抑郁症吗？“是的。”在过去的30天里，你有没有为了生存而不得不做一些让你觉得不安全的事情？“是的。”频率是多少？“每天。”还有更多问题，尤兰达一边交谈一边将蒂莱西亚的回答输入电脑。他们竟然想对她了解得这么多，在蒂莱西亚看来是个好兆头。她感到充满了希望，尽管他们依然睡在车里。声音太大了。什么？
So, what's your favorite food? Spaghetti's chicken and garlic bread with some salad, fish, french fries and salad, Mmm. I like zucchini. Yeah. What's your favorite dessert? You like banana pudding? Now a chocolate cake. Chocolate cake. As cream cake? Ice cream cake. As cream cake. Ice cream cake.
那么，你最喜欢吃什么？意大利面配鸡肉、大蒜面包加沙拉，还有鱼、炸薯条和沙拉，嗯。我喜欢西葫芦。对。你最喜欢什么甜点？你喜欢香蕉布丁吗？现在是巧克力蛋糕。巧克力蛋糕。冰淇淋蛋糕？冰淇淋蛋糕。冰淇淋蛋糕。冰淇淋蛋糕。
Cove cake is some sunny. Sunday. Oh, another has some sunny. You have had a Sunday on the way. Well, Tilecia waited to hear back, but whether she was going to get hope with housing or shelter, she kept going to see Trish. It's interesting with Tilecia, because you try to have boundaries. And there's always one or two or a few,
圣代蛋糕是一种……圣代。哦，另外还有一种圣代。你路上吃过圣代。好吧，蒂莱西亚等待着消息，无论她是否能得到住房或收容所的帮助，她一直坚持去看望崔茜。和蒂莱西亚在一起很有趣，因为你总是试图设立界限。但总有一两个或几个，
and I have a few where the boundary is like, it's really hard to keep that boundary because there's something else they need or they draw it on you. And she demanded it and it happened. It just happened that way and not everybody does that. It wasn't that long before Tilecia started calling Trish big mama and telling her she loved her. The two of them recounted this to me
而我也有几个这样的例子，那界限就像是——真的很难守住这个界限，因为她们有别的东西需要你，或者她们在向你索取。而她提出了要求，而且真的实现了。事情就这么发生了，并不是每个人都能做到这一点。没过多久，蒂莱西亚就开始叫崔茜“大妈妈”（Big Mama），并告诉她自己爱她。两人向我讲述了这一幕，
in Trish's office. Like people don't come in and say I love you. You know what I'm saying? And then I found myself saying it back because she needed it. So that was the demand. She wasn't going to accept anything less. I started saying it because I want to know, you know, I really, I do love her. You're getting emotional, I love you. Of course, I'm always getting emotional. I'm being emotional, creature.
就在崔茜的办公室里。就像人们不会走进来对我说“我爱你”一样。你知道我的意思吗？然后我发现自己也回了一句“我也爱你”，因为她需要它。这就是她的要求。她不接受任何低标准。我开始说这句话是因为我想让她知道，你知道的，我是真的，我确实爱她。你情绪激动了，我爱你。当然，我总是很容易情绪激动。我就是个感情丰富的生物。
I know this side of Tileisha too. I've tried to keep a journalistic boundary with her, but she texts me out of the blue like, hey Katie what are you doing? Or she'd say, I'm sad and I'd find myself giving her a pep talk. Another case in point. For some reason at this very moment in Trisha's office, she was squeezed onto the same chair as me. I'm just squeezed on the chair with you. I don't know there's this whole other chair is me. I'm just squeed on the chair with you. I know there's this whole other chair right? Sorry. I just saw the man. You can't keep a mouth. Oh, sorry.
我也了解蒂莱西亚的这一面。我曾试图与她保持新闻采访的界限，但她会突然发短信给我，比如，“嘿，凯蒂，你在干嘛？”或者她说，“我很伤心，”然后我发现自己正在给她做心理疏导。另一个例子。不知为什么，就在崔茜办公室里的这个时刻，她和我挤在同一把椅子上。我只是跟你挤在一把椅子上。我不知道还有这整整另一把椅子呢。我只是跟你挤在一把椅子上。我知道旁边有整整另一把椅子对吧？抱歉。我只是看到了那个男的。你控制不住自己的嘴。哦，抱歉。
Patricia's support in a place to be every day. Tullisha was finally in an emotional state where she felt like she could work again. And Trisha encouraged her to apply to a temp agency. She did, and she got a temporary position in washing dishes for Cirque du Soleil. In the evenings of Tilly's show had enough money, she'd buy herself and Jordan something to eat for dinner. And Jordan would spread his homework out on the table
有了崔茜的支持，加上每天都有个去处，蒂莱西亚的心理状态终于恢复到了觉得可以重新工作的地步。崔茜鼓励她去申请一家临时工中介机构。她照做了，并得到了一份在太阳马戏团（Cirque du Soleil）洗碗的临时工作。傍晚时分，如果蒂莱西亚有足够的钱，她会给自己和约旦买点晚饭吃。约旦会把家庭作业铺在桌子上，
at KFC or McDonald's. Sometimes she even had enough money to do something fun, like a movie. They were still sleeping in the car, but it felt like maybe things were turning around. I need a county to help my heckin' help you. A couple weeks after that first call, Tileisha tried to one-one again.
在肯德基或麦当劳写作业。有时她甚至有足够的钱做点好玩的事，比如看场电影。他们仍然睡在车里，但感觉事情或许正在好转。我需要县里帮我……真的帮帮我。在那次求助电话几周后，蒂莱西亚再次拨打了211。
Good morning, how you doing? Good thing you're having you. call. Talisha tried to one disability. Okay. The operator asked Tilly she had already done an assessment for the coordinated entry system. She said she had other than referring people into that system where maybe hopefully they'll get assistance with housing. 211 also maintains their own database of subsidized housing options that you don't have to be homeless to get into. Just poor. But all of those options have waiting lists. The waiting list is from one to five years. That's the problem.
早上好，你好吗？很高兴你打来电话。蒂莱西亚尝试……残疾。好的。接线员问蒂莱西亚是否已经做过协调准入系统的评估。她说她做过了。除了将人们转介到该系统、让他们有望获得住房援助之外，211还维护着自己的经济适用房数据库，入住这些房子并不要求无家可归，只需要贫困。但所有这些选项都有等待名单。等待时间从一年到五年不等。这就是问题所在。
They can also give you a list of apartments on the private market that aren't subsidized, but where the landlords might be willing to work with tenants that have less than sparkling rental histories. But there doesn't seem to be much of anything that would be affordable for Tilecia. Okay, there is one, is this a room for rent in Auckland? The price is 600 per person, so you have to be 1200. You can tell the operator thinks 1200 for a room is an absolute garbage option. To my child. I mean, for my own room, no, I try to figure it out.
他们还可以为你提供一份私人市场上的公寓名单，这些公寓没有补贴，但房东可能愿意配合那些租房历史不太完美的租客。但似乎没有什么东西是蒂莱西亚能够负担得起的。好的，有一个，这是奥克兰的一间出租屋。价格是每人600美元，所以你得花1200美元。你可以看出接线员觉得一个房间要1200美元简直是个烂透了的选择。为了我的孩子。我是说，为了我自己的房间，不，我再想想办法。
It is a little bit expensive, but all we need is our own room that we... Tolisha told me later she didn't end up pursuing that room. It was too expensive. Before they hang up, Tolisha asks again about shelter. The operator tells her that the only thing available is for victims of domestic violence. And then asks her, and a tone that can only be described as hopeful if she happens to be one. Yeah, unfortunately, are you a victim of domestic violence?
确实有点贵，但我们需要的只是属于我们自己的房间，我们可以……蒂莱西亚后来告诉我，她最后没有去租那间房。太贵了。在挂断电话之前，蒂莱西亚再次询问了关于庇护所的事。接线员告诉她，目前唯一可用的收容所只为家庭暴力受害者提供，接着用一种只能形容为充满期待的语气问她，她恰好是不是受害者。是的，不幸的是，你是家庭暴力的受害者吗？
In my parents, but not recently, I think. Yeah, first of all, there's nothing available right now. Trish told me she tells all of her homeless parents to call 2-on-1. But for most of them, it doesn't lead to housing, which she doesn't think is 2-1-1's fault, but it's still frustrating. Every time you call, you're getting the same interview over and over and over again, and it's like, they're collecting all this data, but there's no movement. What's a case that's really stuck with you, you know, without naming names, but like, the mom who says, if I don't find housing this year, I'm going to kill myself.
在我父母那里有过，但最近没有，我想。好吧，首先，现在没有什么可用的。崔茜告诉我，她让所有无家可归的父母都去打211。但对他们大多数人来说，这并不能带来住房，她认为这不是211的错，但依然令人沮丧。每次你打电话，你都在经历一遍又一遍、没完没了的相同面谈，这就好像，他们收集了所有这些数据，却没有任何实质进展。有没有哪个案例深深触动了你，当然不用提名字，比如，那个妈妈说，“如果我今年再找不到房子，我就自杀。”
And my kids will be better off without me because at least they're going to foster care and they'll get housed into the, I had two attempted suicides last year. No, this year, I never saw that before. So the mental health has really been on the decline for these families. The stories Trish hears all day from these parents are hard. She tells me while she bangs out a few emails, how she manages to hold so many sad stories. Well my faith is what makes me have more the most capacity to do the work Well, it's just a place to put it all so you don't carry it all the things you can't solve all the things you can't carry because you got to Carry something else.
“我的孩子们没有我会过得更好，因为至少他们会进入寄养系统，他们会住进……”我去年经历了两起未遂自杀。不，是今年，我以前从未见过这种情况。所以这些家庭的心理健康状况确实在不断恶化。崔茜整天从这些父母那里听到的故事都很沉重。她一边敲击着几封邮件，一边告诉我她是如何消化这么多悲伤的故事的。嗯，我的信仰让我拥有了能够胜任这项工作的最大承受力，这只是一个存放它们的地方，这样你就不用背负所有那些你无法解决的事情，不用背负所有你无法承受的东西，因为你还得背负别的东西。
It's a place like, you know, you're purse, you put all your things you need for the day and the purse or a bag or the, it's kinda like that. And so you're able to carry more. Still, Trish says the purse is filling up. And she's not sure how much more it, or she can carry. Yeah, you can't do this forever.
这就好比，你知道的，你的钱包，你把你一天中需要的东西都放进钱包或包里，或者……情况有点像这样。这样你就能承担更多了。不过，崔茜说，钱包已经快满了。她不知道它——或者她自己——还能承载多少。对，你不可能永远这样做。
I've done it for a long time already. Part of what's hard for Trish is that she doesn't feel like she has as much power as she is to make a difference in people's lives. A couple of years ago, Trish could help the family she worked with get into shelters. If she had a family walking at 4pm who had nowhere to sleep that night? She'd start making calls. But then the county shifted to a system where everyone has to go through 2-1-1. And now she can't do that anymore. It's hard to notice someone's on the street, you can't make a phone call and get them into a shelter.
我已经做了很长时间了。对崔茜来说，艰难的一部分在于，她并不觉得自己拥有像她希望的那样多的权力来改变人们的生活。几年前，崔茜可以帮她共事的家庭住进收容所。如果有家庭在下午4点走进办公室，当晚无处可睡呢？她就会开始打电话。但后来，县里转变为一个系统，要求每个人都必须通过211。现在她再也做不到这一点了。很难看到有人流落街头，却不能打个电话帮他们找个收容所。
You know, in this position you have to be careful that you don't become a complainer. You know, in this position, you have to be careful that you don't become a complainer. Because you're having families interact with a system that you don't think is it works or it has challenges and the family is already feeling that. So you walk a fine line in your frustration. This call was the last time Tileisha tried to one one. It's about three weeks from her first call, and she sounds tired. The operator tells her that the only shelters available are for single adults, not for a woman with a child. You know, he a good kid. He just got a 3.0 on his report card, you know. Oh, he's running out of power at the school.
你知道，在这个职位上，你必须小心，不要让自己变成一个爱抱怨的人。你知道，在这个职位上，你必须小心，不要让自己变成一个爱抱怨的人。因为你要让这些家庭去和一个你认为并不管用、或者存在种种挑战的系统打交道，而这些家庭本身就已经深有体会了。所以在你的挫败感中，你必须如履薄冰。这通电话是蒂莱西亚最后一次打211。距离她第一次打电话大约过去三周了，她的声音听起来很疲惫。接线员告诉她，唯一可用的庇护所只针对单身成年人，不接待带着孩子的女性。你知道，他是个好孩子。他的成绩单上刚拿了3.0的绩点，你知道的。哦，他在学校里的精力快用完了。
Yeah. Yeah, he's doing really good and stuff. I don't want to stop all that stuff that he's got going on. Just jumping in here to say that Tilecia is right to be worried about Jordan falling behind academically. Data from public schools in 2017-2018 showed that only 29% of homeless students were proficient in reading, and they were similarly behind in math. But it isn't just poverty that makes them slip. It's instability. Homeless kids' test scores are below even other low-income students who are
对。对，他表现得真的很好之类 的。我不想毁了他已经取得的所有那些成就。在这里插话说明一下，蒂莱西亚担心约旦在学业上落后是完全有道理的。2017-2018学年公立学校的数据显示，只有29%的无家可归学生阅读熟练，他们在数学方面也同样落后。但让他们滑落的不仅仅是贫困。而是动荡。无家可归的儿童的考试成绩甚至低于那些有稳定住所的其他低收入学生。
stably housed. Before they get off the phone, the operator suggests that Alicia get into the coordinated entry system, not seeming to realize that she was already in the system. She'd been in it for weeks now. She hadn't gotten any help. Like, nobody never called me back and checked on me. Like, I've been going through this now for so long. And what do you think that is?
在他们挂断电话之前，接线员建议蒂莱西亚加入协调准入系统，似乎没有意识到她其实已经在这个系统里了。她进这个系统已经好几个星期了。她没有得到任何帮助。就像，从来没有人打电话给我并查看我的情况。就像，我经历这一切已经这么久了。你觉得这是为什么？
There's so many people all over that experience. The same thing as me. Everybody just never got to me on the list. I think I just feel like somebody, they forgot about me. They forgot about me and my son. In other words, for Tullisha, the fact that help never came wasn't personal, and it totally was personal.
到处都有这么多人经历着和我一样的事情。大家只是从来没有轮到单子上的位置。我觉得……我只是觉得有人，他们把我给忘了。他们把我跟我儿子给忘了。换句话说，对蒂莱西亚来说，帮助从未到来这件事既不是针对个人的，但又完完全全是针对个人的。
A couple months after those two-on-one calls, Tullisha still hadn't gotten any help with housing from the system. She had a new job in Napa Auto Parts where she made about $500 a week, but she hadn't been able to save much yet. She had found a spot where she and Jordan could stay inside with some regularity, Not their own place, but somewhere to crash at least. It didn't feel like home though, even though she had a roof over her head. She still felt homeless. There's nothing else for me to do with, keep trying. Yeah. You know, I think about Jordan more than I think about myself. Every night, I just keep listening to that song. Oh, don't change this coming. And I just keep holding on.
在那两次211通话几个月后，蒂莱西亚仍然没有从系统中得到任何住房方面的帮助。她在纳帕汽车零部件公司（Napa Auto Parts）找到了一份新工作，每周大约能赚500美元，但她还没能存下多少钱。她找到了一处她和约旦可以相当规律地在室内居住的地方，不是他们自己的地方，但至少有地方可以借宿了。不过，这感觉不像是家，尽管她头上有了遮风挡雨的屋顶。她依然觉得自己无家可归。我除了继续尝试，别无他法。对。你知道的，我为约旦考虑得比为自己考虑得还要多。每天晚上，我都一遍又一遍地听着那首歌。哦，改变就要来临。我只是在咬牙坚持。
Everything gon' be alright, just hold on. Change this coming. I'm on it right now though, like right, right now. Okay. Thanks for talking to me. Thank you. Always appreciate it. Yep, I feel better too.
一切都会好起来的，坚持住。改变就要来临。不过我现在就在经历这一切，就是现在，此时此刻。好的。谢谢你跟我聊天。谢谢你。一直都很感激。对，我也感觉好多了。
Oh good. I feel like I wore you out, but I'm going. I was already wore out. Yeah. Before you got in there. Alright, well I hope you get some good sleep tonight. I don't know if so too. Well, I hope you get some good sleep tonight. That'll also do.
哦，太好了。我觉得我把你折腾累了，不过我要走了。我本来就已经很累了。对。在你来之前就这样了。好吧，那我希望你今晚能睡个好觉。我也希望如此。好吧，希望你今晚能睡个好觉。那也会有帮助的。
The place where Tullisha and Jordan were staying was a one bedroom basement apartment, where a bunch of other people also lived. One guy slept on the couch, another person slept in a recliner. Tullisha and Jordan slept on a barermatras. Sometimes there were tensions in the house, though. People mad at each other over bills or food or what to watch on TV. And then, Tleisha and Jordan would end up back
蒂莱西亚和约旦借宿的地方是一间一室一厅的地下室公寓，里面还住着其他好几个人。一个家伙睡在沙发上，另一个人睡在躺椅上。蒂莱西亚和约旦睡在一张充气床垫上。不过，屋里有时会有紧张气氛。大家因为账单、食物或看电视看哪个频道而互相生气。然后，蒂莱西亚和约旦就会回到那个他们一直以来唯一可以依靠的地方。车里。我看到星星了。看到星星了吗？对。一旦你看到它们，数一数，然后许个愿。他们说，嗯，你怎么选星星？那是北斗七星，那是小勺子。
in the one place they'd always been able to count on. The car. I see stars. See stars? Yeah. Once you look at them, account them and make a wish. They say, well, how do you choose stores? It's a big, dippered, a little dippered.
小勺子。我做的勺子。对，许多勺子。我做的那本书。对，许多不同的。啊，妈妈。对。恐龙真让人感到难过。你为恐龙感到难过？
Small dippered. I made dippered. Yeah, many dippered. I made the book. Yeah, many different. Ah, ma'am. Yeah. That is so safe at the dinosaurs. You feel sorry for the dinosaurs?
对，它们灭绝了。我不想。你为恐龙感到难过？对，它们很臭。我希望它们。所有的恐龙都去了。两个女儿，两个儿子，还有豌豆包。我想有些没有。有些没去吗？对。
Yeah, they speak. I won't do. You feel sorry for the dinosaurs? Yeah, the stink. I want them. All the dinosaurs go. The two daughters, two sons, the Peabags. I think some don't know. Some of them not going? Yeah.
好吧，然后是笼子，冬眠者。也许吧，对。我想弄明白为什么蒂莱西亚从来没有得到过任何住房帮助。如果这个系统不是在帮助她，那它在帮谁？我确实知道的一件事是，当无家可归的人寻求帮助时，他们几乎总是被建议拨打211。那似乎是所有人的起点。如果我想弄明白这一切是如何运作的，也许我应该去拜访他们一下。
Well, then the cage, the hibernator. Maybe, yeah. I wanted to understand why Tilecia had never gotten any help with housing. Who was this system helping if not her? One thing I did know was that when homeless people wanted help, they were almost always advised to call 2-1-1. That seemed to be the starting place for everyone. If I wanted to understand how this all worked, maybe I should pay them a visit.
下期节目，我们将继续探讨“按需分配”。在我们从插播广告回来之后，是下期节目的预告。下期节目，在“按需分配”中。我叫哈拉姆（Haram），来自阿拉米达县211，想查看一下收容所的床位情况。好的，非常感谢。再见。他们没有任何空位。她当时就想，啊？我该怎么办？什么都没有。
That's next time, on according to need. When we come back from the break, a preview. Next time, on according to need. My name is Haram, calling from Alameda County to one one just checking the shelter space. Okay, thank you very much. One by say. They don't have anything available. She's like so, huh? What I got to do is nothing.
哪里都没有。她就想，所以我跟我孩子今晚真的要流落街头了吗？早上好。感谢您致电……他们不能把人丢在不管。我是阿拉米达县无家可归者，带着两岁的儿子，但我愿意搬到任何能得到帮助的地方。我会做出反应，我会提前通知你们，给出一个洗澡的……我今年93岁。
It's nowhere. She's like so me and my child are really about to be on the streets tonight. Good morning. Thank you for calling on me. They can't leave someone out. I'm home with the Alameda County with the two year old son, but I'm willing to move anywhere that I can get help. I would react and I would do y'all know in advantage and give a wash and a three. I'm 93 years old.
这里没有人，这里没有人。不，我被卡住了。你需要在下午6点前赶到EOCP。嘿，我要出来了。我马上出来。卡米，快点。她想说她实际上无家可归，但我想她实际上一直住在朋友家，或者她最后会这么说。
No one here, he's no one here. No, I'm stuck. You need to get over to EOCP by 6pm. Hey, I'm coming out. I'm coming out right here. Kami, want to hurry. She wants to say she's literally homeless, but I think she's actually been staying at a front house or she's going to end up saying that.
当你告诉人们他们不属于“实质意义上的无家可归”时，他们真的会非常沮丧。我他妈的就睡在车里，我昨晚才刚被放进来。为什么有些无家可归的人甚至无法进入这个系统？接听他们的电话又是怎样的体验？接下来将在“按需分配”中播出。本期节目由我凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）制作，助理制作人为阿比·梅顿（Abbie Medon），执行主编为惠特尼·亨利·莱斯特（Whitney Henry Lester）。罗曼·莫里斯（Roman Morris）担任监制。
People are really good frustrated when you tell them they're not literally homeless. I'm sleeping in my effing car and I just got let in last night. Why some homeless people never even make it into the system and what it's like to answer their calls? That's coming up on a courting to need was produced by me, Katie Mingle, with associate producer Abbie Medon and managing editor Whitney Henry Lester. Roman Morris was the executive producer.
特别感谢丽莎·波洛克（Lisa Pollock）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）提供的宝贵编辑意见。凯文·拉姆齐（Kevin Ramsay）担任我们的录音师，艾米·盖恩斯（Amy Gaines）负责事实核查。动听的音乐由才华横溢的肖恩·拉尔（Sean Raell）创作，品牌与设计由muchmore.io提供。库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）担任我们的数字总监，索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sofia Klatsker）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Leigh）和克里斯·佩鲁韦（Chris Perube）提供了额外支持。
In valuable editing from Lisa Pollock, Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Christopher Johnson, and Joe Rosenberg. Kevin Ramsay was our sound engineer, fact checking by Amy Gaines. Beautiful music by the beautiful Sean Raell, branding and design by muchmore.io. Kurt Colstead was our digital director, additional support from Sofia Klatsker, Vivian Leigh,
特别感谢所有在本系列节目中接受我采访的人，以及玛丽索尔·梅迪纳-克雷娜（Marisol Medina-Kerena）、艾莉森·德永（Allison DeYoung）和切尔西·米勒（Chelsea Miller）。“按需分配”是99%隐形（99% Invisible）的一个项目，由PRX发行。
and Chris Perube. Special thanks to all the people who spoke to me for this series, as well as Marisol Medina-Kerena, Allison DeYoung, and Chelsea Miller. According to Need, is a project of 99% invisible, which is distributed by PRX. Radio Tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
电台塔皮奥。来自PRX。你本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。